fossé opposé à noël le graët le
président de la fédération française
football donc son président voilà à
propos de l'homophobie qui a dit qu'ils
vont faire arrêter les matchs pour le
racisme n'est pas le mot phobie alors
arrêtez bouilloire pour l'homophobie
aussi on va on va voir la vidéo no les
grès de ses fans y arrivait beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui se sont exprimé là
dessus noël le graet a demandé aux
arbitres de ne plus arrêter les matchs
lorsque des chants homophobes étaient
entonnés dans les tribunes et antoine
griezmann attaquant de l'équipe de
france franchement il ya eu des cojones
parce qu'il est allé contre son
président et il a pris la parole vous
regardez donc la borne le graet et après
on va voir antoine griezmann c'est notre
coup de coeur j'arrêterai pas le match
que quelques spectateurs exagéré oui oui
j'accepte pas on va faire en sorte que
ça disparaisse
mais l'arrêt des matchs autre chose et
je veux pas être pris en otage sur
l'homophobie c'est pas vrai on a ya pas
d'omerta et à une volonté farouche de
faire en sorte effectivement qu'on
puisse être sur un stade de façon très
ligne est tout à fait amicale et en
famille mais l'arrêt des matches ne
m'intéresse pas donc vous demander aux
arbitres de ne plus arrêter des matches
c'est une erreur qu'on arrête tu as un
match j'arrêterai un match trop tôt et
cris racistes ça c'est clair
les scieries donkey antoine griezmann
qui allait à l'encontre des déclarations
de son président l'attaquant de l'équipe
de france s'est montré favorable à
l'interruption des matches en cas de
chants ou banderole homophobe c'est
franchement c'est incroyable qu'ils
soient les enr contre le président de la
fédération français de football
on l'écouté antoine griezmann pour nous
c'est très bien ne rien arrêter les
matches et pour moi c'est pareil que
soient les champs contre l'homophobie ou
le rat c'est absolument pas rêve si on
arrête les magmas les gens sauront
moins contents ils arrêteront de le
faire alors qu'antoine a été contre son
président emmanuel macron également le
président quelle également donné son
avis sur la question
vous allez voir son a dit dans un
instant géraldine muhlmann il est
toujours à la pointe il est toujours à
l'avant garde
il ya que 3 footeux qui ont fait la
couverture de têtu ya griezmann adil
rami ouais et olivier giroud et que
c'est toujours pour un jeu dans un monde
qui est très machiste malgré tout est
aussi oui mais pas footballeurs coûtent
plus que le tien je me débrouille du
modem d'ailleurs olivier giroud je
t'appelle époque je n'ai pas oublié
aweys qui m'a dit ça mais ça je n'ai pas
oublié louis et bien moi pardon je
trouve ses trois choristes qu'il est
faux antoine griezmann même si je pense
que je pense linverse de saïdi c'est à
dire que à mon avis il faut punir
fermement ceux qui le font il faut
arriver à les identifier
mais en revanche ça veut dire quoi se
dire que demain des supporters qui sera
en train de perdre et qui ne support ait
là un match est pour l'arrêter a voulu
mettre à crier des trucs soir à 6 oui
mais ça arrive et ça arrive à leur
équipe
ça va arriver ils vont arrêter un match
oui je pense qu'il faut identifier
aujourd'hui ces gens là ils font d
interdire de stade et il faut arrêter de
faire payer n'importe qui pour n'importe
quoi
donc je pense qu'effectivement c'est une
mauvaise décision d'abord j'aimerais
pouvoir il a levé la main avant je me
serais qui sait que c'est maintenant et
vous qu'est ce que tu veux chez lui qui
donne son ami vous êtes qui monsieur
alors je suis l'année de franck
gastambide très bien compris
non mais je crois qu'après le magnéto
[Rires]
fort le courage de dire que ça va être
très long parce que c'est une question
d'éducation
ça va prendre des années n'y a pas un
coup de baguette magique où les gens
vont arrêter d'être con vont arrêter
d'être assistés de mox à prendre des
années mais c'est une question
d'éducation faut parler aux supporters
et petit à petit ça va s'arranger mais
arranger les matches il faut régler la
plupart des supporters sont top
moi je vais me taper par des supporters
on les oublie qu'il est fou il excuse
qui consiste à dire que les supporters
vont s'en servir quand il perd même âge
de fer décrit comme ça pour que le bal
ce soir et blessures c'est sûr mais les
supporters les identifier dans un stade
si si les supporters du cmit hyper fait
ça le match est perdu sa bien sûr alors
emmanuel macron a donné son avis sur la
question
emmanuel macron qui est le président de
supporteurs de foot moi je sais en tout
cas comment j'organiserai les choses je
serai des insultes cinq minutes de la
fin d'un match que je suis en train de
perdre bon donc il faut être intraitable
sur le fond il faut que les discours de
haine qu'il soit raciste ou homophobe
cesse ça suppose un engagement de toute
la famille du football
ils ont qu'à ministre est dans son rôle
en demandant et je pense ensuite qu'il
faut du pragmatisme du bon sens c'était
la ligue et au club de le faire avec
leurs associations de supporters et
voilà progressivement qu'on améliore les
choses la ligue l'a signé une charte
contre l'homophobie en 2009 ça fait dix
ans que la ligue française de foot se
bat contre l'homophobie
la fédération française de football noël
le graet a aussi une charte pour lutter
contre l'homophobie et la fifa aussi
donc noël le graet il est complètement à
côté de la plaque jaune ou ados petite
échelle j'ai un petit club de foot mois
qui s'appelle l'atletico de marseille
voilà et à notre petite échelle
notre prochain match on a refait faire
des maillots voilà pour lutter contre
l'homophobie et les joueurs joueront
dans les stades et les joueurs joueront
avec ce maillot
donc voilà dès lors rien au charme à ce
sera
j'embrasse est en marche tous les jours
il ya noël le graet qui peut coûter en
tout cas compter sur le soutien de
didier deschamps
donc le sélectionneur qui a interrogé
sur le sujet en conférence de presse
regarder ces racks je connais bien
depuis plusieurs années elle c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours lutté contre
toutes les discriminations
après je vais pas rentrer dans la
polémique et en rajouter vous connaissez
ma position et je l'est déjà
je voulais déjà dit voilà évidemment
qu'on aspire tous à ce que y ait pas de
problème mais à un moment donné ça fait
des années qu'on entend des gens comme
ça qui parle pour ne rien dire
dix fois appelé au bon sens la france ça
marche pas que du bon sens ça marche
avec des sanctions
je suis désolé le bon temps ça veut rien
dire ce qu'il faudrait maintenant c'est
créer comme dans le métro comme partout
une police du football des policiers qui
soit qu'ils soient dans les tribunes du
temps mais qui arrive à identifier les
gens sont les sorts le bon sens mais
serré le bon sens c'est comme si vous
disiez des gens roulaient pas 150 sur
autoroute mais à 120 c'est du bon sens
celui ci a pas de sanction les gens
sentent à des sanctions il ya plein de
gens attendaient je crois qu isabelle
morini-bosc un truc intéressant à dire
oui kristen jeu-là d'or mais honnêtement
je pense qu'il fait une erreur de
jugement quand il dit quand il dit c'est
ouais moi il y aura de gens qui
réagissent et qui font des conneries
dans les salles c'est pas vrai c'est
incitatif d'arrêter un match le moins 2
1 qui va se dire oh mais moi j'ai le
pouvoir d'achat un truc homophobe c'est
ce que vous désirez vous avez reçue à ce
que vous nommez faut sanctionner c'est
tout avec les vidéosurveillances on y
arrive
alors il ya aussi un autre gars qui sait
qui s'exprimait sur le sujet c'est rené
malleville le célèbre aux supporters de
l'om
il était ce matin sur ses news on
voulait voir il évoque le sujet à sa
manière erronée c'est nous qu'on pouvait
écouter il ya 15 ans 20 ans ou 30 ans
dans un stade
ces mots aujourd'hui on ne peut plus les
entendre est ce que vous pouvez prendre
cet engagement rené malleville je
m'emballe playboy chacun est où ta femme
est là d'avallone ou jupes et le bo van
tam est vanité mort et un jours merci
rené c'est un plaisir en tout cas de
vous avoir
[Applaudissements]
sympathique voilà vous savez que j'aime
beaucoup pardonné sa montagne voilà et
sa retenue
[Rires]
cet écart c'est quand même la familia
voilà donc merci on va si vous savez que
la fifa peut prendre des sanctions la
philo qui la fifa la fédération
internationale de foot de prendre des
sanctions contre la fédération française
de foot si nabawi si enfin si elles ne
respectent pas les règles de la vie la
possible s'épousent ça bien sûr la finma
joue du violon je te veux si tu veux
balavoine bas mot merci heureusement que
tu es là